- I don't usually eat pork.
Am I going to be eating pork?
(upbeat music)
- This looks Asian.
- Oh, this looks familiar.
- I think it's meat.
But these days I feel like you can
make anything look like meat.
- I think this is called garb.
- It looks like some kind of appetizer.
- Lob!
- It smells good.
- Really fresh and kind
of, like, it has a sort of
like tangy smell to it.
- Oh it's ground meat, I mean it's kind of
the color of maybe like turkey or pork.
- Bite into it and I'm expecting Thai.
- This is kind of gross.
- It's spicy, it's sweet, it's tangy,
it's got peanuts in it.
I just swallowed a pepper.
- At the beginning it
was fine but right now
I was like, I need water.
- It's a little bit of
spicy but I love it.
- Are you going to say
I'm eating rat meat?
Because it's delicious.
- I would guess pork or turkey still
but I know it can't be that because
that seems boring.
- What, that's so crazy.
I want more, to try more.
- Boiled pig ears?
It's good.
Pig ears are good.
- They must boil it
like really really well.
Because this tastes like very boiled.
- Asian people like using
all parts of the animal.
You waste none of it.
- I imagine ears tasting
more like cartilage.
- To be honest I wouldn't have tried this
if I knew before what it was
but now after I tried it, it's not bad.
- It doesn't taste like rat.